linear and logistic regression are some
of the most commonly used methods
in applied statistics and data science
for the newcomers though
a question that doesn't get asked nearly
enough
is when and why you should use these
methods in the first place
well keep watching because we're going
to talk about that
[Music]
hello again everyone and welcome back to
my channel if this is your first time
here my name is richard
and this is richard on data the channel
where i help you break into data science
and grow your skills in the field
so i know this happens because i saw it
myself in academia
but a lot of people will start out by
learning regression through the math
and the matrix interpretation the
estimate of the slope vector is equal to
the
inverse of x transposed times x
then times that by x transpose times y
interesting i'm not knocking
understanding that by any means that's
not what i'm trying to do here
there is a tremendous amount of value
that comes from understanding the
mathematical underpinnings of regression
or
quite frankly from any model you choose
to use but you'll quickly find yourself
in a situation where you're trying to
solve a real world problem for a client
and you don't want to catch yourself
asking is regression truly the best way
to attack this problem
so i'm going to give a super brief
overview of what linear and logistic
regression
are broaden that discussion to supervise
learning and what the goals of these
types of exercises are in the first
place
and then how you should think through
these problems and how to attack them
before i do that though
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already hit the notification bell
and smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm
then if you guys would like to support
my channel above and beyond that
i'll have links in the description of
the video to my paypal and patreon
accounts
as well as to my crypto wallet addresses
your support is highly appreciated
all right so let's start off with what
the regression methods even are in the
first place
and if you're familiar with this already
feel free to skip ahead in the video
but let's start from the premise that we
have a data set that's in tidy format
that is every cell contains a value
every row contains an observation and
every column contains a variable
then let's suppose we have one variable
that represents some kind of outcome
or response that we're interested in and
we're typically going to represent this
with the letter y
now that outcome variable might be
continuous or discrete
and if it's continuous then you're
looking at a linear regression problem
if your response variable is discrete
though well then that gets a little
trickier
suppose your response variable has two
distinct
levels often then we'll just call one of
those levels
success and the other failure and under
those circumstances your data set is a
candidate for what's known as binomial
logistic regression
which is often just referred to simply
as logistic regression
we'll cover that more in a little bit
here granted if that response variable
has more than two levels
you have extensions in multinomial
logistic regression
and there are ways to approach that
problem depending on whether those
levels are nominal or if they're ordinal
but anyway back to the whole rest of the
data set
so for all the rest of the variables
there's a lot of names we can call those
explanatory variables features
covariates predictors
my favorite term is predictors also
let's refer to these as the x's
in fact for now let's just suppose we
have two variables
the response variable y and a predictor
x and for this example we're going to
use the super basic
mpg data set from r well suppose you
want to understand the relationship
between these two variables
the first thing that you're probably
going to want to do is create a scatter
plot of them
so you end up with something like this
and you very quickly get the general
idea that as the x variable
displacement increases the y variable
highway miles per gallon decreases
you can also generate the correlation
coefficient which is one of the most
frequently used metrics even if it's not
the most interpretable
in and of itself and it's negative 0.766
here
so already we're beginning to learn a
few pieces of information
about the relationship between the y
variable highway miles per gallon
and the x variable which is displacement
a regression model
is going to formalize our understanding
of this relationship
you fit a linear regression model
generate output like this
and suddenly yes our understanding of
that relationship
is formalized and we have tangible
information that we can take away
for example most importantly the
estimate of the slope parameter on
displacement
is negative 3.5306
meaning for every one unit change in
engine displacement
we expect highway miles per gallon to
decrease by 3.5306
units and then also multiple r squared
is 0.5868
meaning 58.68 of the variation in
highway miles per gallon
is explained by this model specifically
the linear relationship
on engine displacement so that super
simple model was created by
like all regression models are through
the concept of least
squares that is by finding the line
that minimizes the sum of the squared
residuals
residuals being the difference between
our observed values
that is the y and the fitted values
let's call that y hat so we can take
this same concept
and essentially project it into multiple
dimensions
where the effects of multiple different
variables on the response
are analyzed and controlled for for
example this model where
once again the response variable is
highway miles per gallon
but we also introduce a variable for the
number of engine cylinders
the drivetrain and class of car on top
of that displacement variable that we
had in the model before
suddenly we have a lot more information
let's take for example the variable
class now this is a factor variable that
estimates the effect on highway miles
per gallon
for different classes of car now all of
these
are relative to some baseline now you
have to do a little bit of digging
through the data set
and you find out that the baseline is a
class of
two-seater so holding everything else
constant
a compact class is expected to have a
highway miles per gallon
of 3.8536 less than a two-seater
plus also of interest is the fact that
the estimate for the slope parameter for
displacement
has changed around a lot recall in our
previous example
it was negative 3.5306
now it's negative 0.3203
so there you go are you getting the idea
so far
that linear regression really helps you
understand relationships
and how a particular variable of
interest affects
some response variable and then we don't
have to repeat this same exercise for a
logistic regression because essentially
you get the same information from that
but i'll have a link in the description
of this video to an r tutorial i've done
where i basically interpret every single
piece of output from both linear
regression
and logistic regression but in short you
get to understand how the log
odds of the outcome that is the natural
log
of the probability of success divided by
the probability of failure
changes with various predictors very
similar premise to linear regression
even if the mechanics are a little bit
different
now i want to take a moment zoom out to
30 000 feet here
and look at the broader type of methods
that linear or logistic regression
fit into in the first place and what the
overall
purpose of any of these methods can be
regression models
are a type of supervised learning method
now what is supervised learning you
might ask
well broadly speaking it's any type of
problem where you have the kind of data
set i've described up to this point
that is you have a response variable and
you have a set of potential explanatory
variables or predictors
contrast that with unsupervised learning
where there is no
known response variable at all and often
in those types of problems
our goal is dimensionality reduction so
we might use a technique like principal
component analysis
but probably more often our goal is to
create our own classes or clusters
so when you got one of those supervised
learning problems and you have a fully
defined response variable
well there's really two types of things
you might want to do here
and those are inference and prediction
i've done a whole video on the
difference between these two
where i really go into detail of
examples of them
you can find that in the description but
i'll briefly go over the difference here
if your goal is inference then you want
to infer
how the various predictors or often just
one single predictor influences the
response variable
you want to understand that relationship
or those various relationships
as best as possible so you probably care
most
about maximizing the goodness of fit of
the model
and there's various metrics for that
such as adjusted r squared
pseudo r squared for logistic regression
aic
bic the list goes on and on whereas in
the case of prediction
that's when you want to build a model
that can with the most accuracy
predict the response variable suppose
you were given a brand new data set
where you knew
all the predictors but the response
variable at that time
was unknown well then you would want to
be able to take your model
run it and get as close to the true
response variable
as possible there's tons of real life
scenarios where that kind of thing
applies now let's suppose you have a
continuous response variable
your goal is probably going to be to
minimize a metric like root mean square
error granted you may run into
circumstances where
predicting too high is worse than
predicting too low
or vice versa but that's usually the
kind of approach you're going to take
if your response variable is categorical
though
that gets a little bit more complicated
and nuanced
now i talk about these considerations in
my r tutorial series on carrots
that'll be in the description too but
still this is broadly a whole
separate video topic you'll notice that
almost everything i've described so far
about what a regression method has going
for it
pertains to inference specifically that
really is
where regression methods shine they
dissect
the variation in the response variable
in linear terms
and are easily interpretable you could
say that they're so simple
even your clients will understand them
but these and other statistical methods
aren't necessarily designed for
prediction
and yes there usually is a trade-off
between inference and prediction
granted it's difficult to find studies
or rigorous analyses on this
because every problem is a little bit
different
but it's generally agreed that machine
learning methods that rely on novel
algorithms
and detect complex patterns for example
neural networks
are going to be superior for predictive
purposes now there is one possible
approach to regression that
sort of strikes a balance between the
two goals though and that's
regularization
specifically the two most common ways we
can skin this cat
are l2 regularization also known as
ridge regression
and l1 regularization also known as
lasso regression or just the lasso this
is another topic for which i could do a
whole separate video on the distinction
between these two
but i'll try to boil it down as simply
as possible
in essence there is a penalty in both of
these
for having two large estimates of slope
coefficients
as your slope coefficient estimates
increase that leads to high variance and
overfitting
and you're trying to correct for that by
introducing some bias
and the single most important
distinction between these two methods
is that the lasso can actually reduce
your slope estimates
all the way to zero remember that at the
slope
representing the rise in the response
over the run
of the predictor is zero that predictor
is essentially useless
because it means there's literally no
linear relationship between the
predictor and the response
so the lasso is actually helping us
perform feature selection and even get
rid of some variables in our model
ridge regression though doesn't do that
you may end up in a scenario where your
slope coefficient estimates are going
pretty close to zero
but they're never actually going to go
all the way to zero
so ridge regression does not double as a
feature selection approach
in the way that the lasso does so if you
take either of these two regularization
approaches
you'll finish up and you have a
regression model still
and it's probably going to perform a
little bit better for predictive
purposes
but you've lost some of that beauty of
interpretability that comes with the
ordinary least
square solution and that's because you
have biased
slope coefficient estimates now how
exactly are you going to interpret those
and explain those to people now
not to mention if you're using the lasso
you might have even dropped off one of
the terms that you wanted to understand
more about the way it influences the
response variable in the first place
so you see this is all a trade-off and
it all comes down to understanding
what the purpose of your analysis is in
the first place
one final idea that i'll leave you with
though is that you don't have to be
monolithic
for the same analysis or exercise you
can try multiple models
and in fact when the goal is prediction
it's perfectly common to ensemble
predictions
over multiple different classifiers or
multiple different models
but even for inference every algorithm
is different
and every practitioner is painfully
aware of all the assumptions that linear
regression carries
for example normality and constant
variance of the residuals
truly linear relationships between the
predictors and the response
and you have minimal multicollinearity
you should probably check these things
out especially if your goal is inference
but you can tell a very interesting
overall story
if on top of a regression method you
also use some other statistical method
or machine learning method
that can be used in and of itself to
tell an inferential story
if you've got the same covariates that
are super important
both based on the absolute value of a t
statistic
from a regression method as well as the
mean decrease in genie index from a
random forest
you probably got yourself a pretty
robust result
but if these things tell wildly
different stories
it couldn't hurt to try to understand or
come up with a hypothesis
for why that is to summarize this whole
discussion
i personally love regression methods and
i use them all the time
especially when i'm trying to create a
baseline for predictive performance to
see how much better machine learning
methods are doing
or if i'm trying to tell a story to my
client about how one predictor or
multiple
predictors exactly influence some
response variable
but don't make regression methods and
exercise in trying to fit a round peg
into a square hole use them with
intentionality
for the right kinds of problems so
thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it smash the like button
and also leave me a comment down below
and let me know do you like
regression methods yourself do you hate
them and you're all in on machine
learning
let me know what you think then i'll see
you all in the not so distant future
until then richard on data